morning resorts along the strip coming
back to life conventions coming back to
town
so also coming back is an old way to
move around the monorail coming back to
life today after being shut down for
almost a year and a half bianca holmen
is there
at the monorail with all the details hi
bianca
good morning nate so yeah this reopens
at seven
this morning so exciting and it's so
important and just to tell us how
important it is because like you said
just in time for all the conventions and
events coming back to las vegas
i'm joined by lori nelson crafts tell us
how important the reopening of the
monorail is
the monorail is really an important
solution to help move our visitors
around to ease congestion in and around
the destination
and pre-pandemic more almost 5 million
passengers
utilize the monorail and you know runs
all the way from the sahara to mgm so it
really
has been an important solution for
us as we market the destination and it's
a great solution for our environment
tell us how green it is it is you're
looking
at an all-electric system running on
zero emissions so
annually over two million vehicle miles
are saved
and reduced off our roads and over 27
tons of emissions reduced as well and so
really a fantastic system for
convenience
but green is definitely a priority with
the monorail
perfect way to go and also again i think
about
those who are going to come and ride it
what is that experience like for them
you know again are there still
some coven measures in place for riders
there is as you know public
transportation still requires a mask
and we're going through extra cleaning
and sanitation always going to be a top
priority
but it's a fun convenient way to get in
and around the destination and we are so
excited to be reopening it this morning
and it's easy on your body it's easy on
the environment because who wants to
walk
three and a half miles up and down the
strip this is great where are some of
the stops that people can
have on the monorail right all the way
from as far north as sahara to mgm and
you've got
flamingo and the link and and right here
at the convention center and that's a
really big important piece for our
convention attendees they utilize this
monorail system
very frequently when they're here in
town all right perfect so we got more
coming up here in our next half hour
and again this opens up seven this
morning so again
great feature at a part of las vegas
that
lets us know we're getting back to
normal slowly but surely send it back to
you guys in the studio